bonjour à tous ici big flo et oli vous
êtes bien sur france 24
[Musique]
on va dire c'est un truc un peu plus
léger pour les réseaux la voilà
[Musique]
à
je crois qu'on l'a compris récemment et
on assume depuis peu ce qui fait notre
force c'est notre différence et notre
complémentarité avant pensait d'eux et
on assume d'être un plus un et je crois
que c'est fort comme ça
oui ça fait deux ans fait un peu plus un
cap de mais en fait un plus un tu
définis et deux identités alors que deux
tu réunis tous dans une sorte de mélange
à
[Musique]
combattants je dirais police
en deux mots combattants dans un
combattant au lit
moi je verrais sensible avec tout ce que
ça comporte pour mon cas
j'ai pas aimé
les autres c'est no parce que dans
l'album on parle beaucoup des autres et
on s'est rendu compte que en parlant des
autres on avait toujours une partie de
nous au final et je trouve que ma
réponse est nickel franchement je
l'avais pas préparer celle là et je leur
ai utiliserait dans votre interview ce
qui est personnel et universel on l'a
très bien aussi
les concerts le contact avec notre
public mais au bout d'un moment ça
commence à manquer
[Musique]
merci d'être encore là franchement il y
avait d'autres choix il y avait d'autres
choix et vous avez continué à écouter
d'une folie donc ça fait plaisir c'est
pas fini non vraiment alors mon père ça
les amuse nouvel album le 24 juin
également les autres c'est nous salut
les gars on y va